i
[Música]
ah
en la región del magreb siguen
incrementando los casos de kobe 19 sobre
todo aquí en marruecos donde se están
registrando alrededor de 5000 casos
diarios se ha vuelto a prolongar el
estado de emergencia sanitaria y también
en túnez aumentan los contagios se ha
vuelto a imponer el toque de queda
nocturnos restricciones de movilidad e
incluso se han cerrado centros
educativos cabe tener en cuenta que en
estos dos países han marruecos y túnez
no solamente aumentan los contagios sino
también la urgencia socioeconómica por
su fuerte dependencia del turismo y en
argelia situación excepcional tras
conocerse que el presidente de la
republica del màgic de abuná se
encuentra hospitalizado en alemania
contagiado por covite 19 además su
evacuación de argelia se coincidió con
el referéndum constitucional en el que
al final solamente votó el 20% de una
sociedad cada vez más alejada de las
instituciones mientras en libia se
mantienen las cifras de kobe 19 y
también el alto al fuego pactado en el
recién iniciado proceso de paz
[Música]
ellos son apenas más de 20.000 casos
confirmados por el 19 en costa de marfil
220 escasos activos y menos 230 muertes
según las cifras oficiales costa de
marfil es uno de los países del mundo
menos afectados por este virus en marzo
cuando se produjo el primer caso
abiyán estuve completamente aislada del
resto del país durante varias semanas el
país también había cerrado sus fronteras
todas estas medidas han frenado
considerablemente el virus pero las
consecuencias económicas son difíciles
para la población los precios de algunos
productos cotidianos han aumento costa
de marfil es un poco como sus vecinos de
la gestión cocina caso y ghana que tiene
un número de muertos muy
nigeria el país más poblado del
continente tiene el mayor número de
casos en áfrica del muestra
i
mientras que europa atraviesa una
segunda ola de kobe 19 aquí en el sur de
áfrica la situación se ha mantenido
estable en las últimas semanas sudáfrica
por ejemplo ha promediado menos de 2.000
casos diarios
recientemente las restricciones se
mantienen sobre todo el toque de queda a
partir de la medianoche pero gran parte
de la actividad económica y deportiva se
ha reactivado parte de la activación
también implica la apertura del espacio
aéreo esta ha sido de gran importancia
considerando que ahora que se aproxima
el verano en el sur del continente miles
de turistas suelen venir en esta época
del año se espera sin duda que este año
vamos a recibir menos visitantes de los
habituales pero sin embargo el gobierno
ha implementado algunas medidas
especiales que motiven a los turistas
extranjeros a venir la reactivación de
la economía que ha sido gravemente
afectada por la pandemia dependerá
también del turismo local que ha estado
paralizado después de varios meses de
estricto confinamiento
[Música]